a lot of viewers and Julie Chen dubbed
this season big Paul
[Music]
two summers in a row are in the same
position look it's very Gumpy to say the
least but uh Here I am once again
one short vote away and it is what it is
honestly what do you think happened cuz
a lot of those jury votes surprised
viewers they honestly surprised me a
little bit too but I think everybody was
pissed
I was only bet in the house I don't know
what they expected me to do to like roll
over and just give them the game but I
wasn't gonna do that so I think when
they got to jury they realized Oh Paul
beat us well I hate him now so that's
about that witch vote surprised you the
most
Alex Jason Cody definitely surprised me
I didn't think there would be anything
on planet earth sitting next to Josh
that Cody would vote for but apparently
I'm it so you said it was just a game
and that we'd be friends afterwards if
that's true then let's be friends
otherwise I'm voting for the person who
stabbed me in the front instead of the
back
it's like crying over a game of Monopoly
like who I won 50 grand I'm stoked
whatever if they didn't want to vote for
me that's on them they could live with
that
whatever weirdness to have inside of
them I know I played the hell out of
this season I gave it all that I could
and if I still dictated 2nd place then
that's what I dictated me and I'll take
it put my head up and walk out with
friendship boys Trejo
whatever the hell you want to say Here I
am two stars in a row do you want to
come back and play again next summer
look I put a hundred ninety one days
into this house over six months of my
life has been lived inside the Big
Brother house I'm definitely insane I'm
on all aspects of sociopaths I would
probably do it again
why sadomasochists absolutely but I
would totally do it again and hopefully
at this point I just want to win second
place all the time just to keep the
ongoing joke running I just want to win
second place forever so if they bring me
back I'm shooting for second victor and
Nicole aren't dating
holy holy earth like I thought that was
a joke he's like oh this is my
girlfriend I was like shut up Victor
what's up Nick and then they
and I was like all right well that's
happening now I wish them luck that's
super bizarre hope a weird baby comes
out of it that'll be slightly hairy and
slightly like nerdy all at once I'm into
it
like I love Victor and Nicole both
dearly so I'm soaked
I don't know how Ori feels about it or I
don't know what other people do about it
but obviously I'm out of the loop